can now officially confirm I've just had  it through from a government Source the  chancellor has been sacked he has lost  his job quasi-cartang is no longer the  chancellor and Liz trust is going to  appoint someone out you can see it on  your screen now I just read out the full  thing quasi quatang's resignation letter  to Liz trust well I say resignation he  makes it clear at the top that he was  sacked you have asked me to stand aside  now critically for Liz truss in that  letter what you see is quasiquartang  still being supportive of the Prime  Minister saying that he will support her  from the back benches so a difficult  resignation speech from the back bench  is calling for Liz truss's resignation  doesn't seem to be there so obviously  she's asked him to stand aside to in  order to save her own Premiership